[Music]
my next guest hosts the Comedy Central
show Nathan for you where he offers
unorthodox advice to struggling
businesses here's what he did for an
independent coffee shop hi I'm Nathan
fielder president and founder of dumb
Starbucks a brand new coffee experience
located in Los Angeles California by
adding the word dumb we are legally
allowed to use the coveted Starbucks
name and logo because we've fulfilled
the minimum requirements to be
considered a parody under US law we have
a full menu including all your favorite
Starbucks items a delicious selection of
pastries and even some music for the
ride home come in and get a free coffee
on me just say Nathan
[Applause]
Nathan thanks so much for being here
we're huge fans of what you're doing and
first of all two things I want to
congratulations you just got renewed for
a third season I did I loved your turn
to the crowd well what of it yes you are
to be congratulated this dump this is
what's important for people to know who
don't know and I many people know about
it cuz it was such a phenomenon this was
real you found a struggling coffee shop
and you renamed it dumb Starbucks well
it's yeah it started as a way to help a
struggling coffee shop get instant brand
recognition because people would come in
thinking it's a Starbucks but it was
legal because we were using parody law
but it actually the owner of the coffee
shop was a bit you know he wasn't
pulling his end of the load and so I
ended up kind of getting greedy and
doing it by myself right and you know
taking the idea away from him mm-hmm in
a way you know way you know I I let my
guard down and the devil climbed inside
me he not only turned on the ignition
but he also drove way above the speed
limit this thing got has that ever
happened to you oh yeah with the devil
yeah oh yeah yeah that's how I got this
job I'm curious how did this high that's
all right don't worry it's good to see
I brought something for Andy actually if
it's okay sure it's a gun oh oh look at
that
it's an iTunes gift card that's so nice
I don't think anyone's ever brought a
gift for Andy before so I know you
probably make a little lesson a little
bit a little bit
it's like Groban you know I'm here and
he's right there all right yeah this
this over there that's to where that I
didn't get a gift card this thing got
out of hand
you had lines around the block you had
media from all over the world we only
have a picture of a press conference you
gave in front of them there were
protesters there too protesting what I
don't know I guess protestors look for a
crowd and then they go there right way
out of control
you have a way sometimes of getting
people especially probably I'm sure
Starbucks didn't love that who can say
who cares